con la consigna volvemos a pastel se
lleva adelante este acto aquí en la
ciudad de buenos aires para ser en la
calle en la que se encuentra el edificio
de la asociación mutual israelita
argentina es el nuevo edificio del
antiguo edificio también estaba y fue el
que fue destruido por el atentado con
bomba en
1994 y la vuelta a pasar tiene que ver
con que durante los dos años de pandemia
de kobe 19 más duros no se pudo hacer en
forma presencial este acto conmemorativo
y de pedido de justicia por las 85
víctimas mortales los más de 300 heridos
causados por encia atentado el más
grande en su tipo nar que tiene uno de
los más importantes en américa latina'
aquí en argentina cuya comunidad judía
es de las más grandes del mundo y las
más importantes número de aquí de
américa latina